lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
explorar los valores posicionales que
involucran decimales en particular vamos
a analizar cómo reagrupar los valores de
una posición a otra algo que le será muy
útil más adelante cuando comiencen a
realizar aritmética con decimales
primero analicemos cuál es este número
cada cuadrado representa una unidad o un
entero quién número es este vemos que
tenemos tres unidades enteras por lo que
escribimos tres luego observamos que
este entero está dividido en diez barras
verticales iguales por lo que cada barra
es una décima y cuatro de ellas están
coloreadas por lo que son tres unidades
cuatro décimas y en esta parte una
unidad está dividida en 100 secciones
iguales
esa es una cuadrícula de 10 x 10 y
podemos ver que 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 de ellas
están coloreadas esto representa 7
centésimas
esto es 3.4 7 o 3 y 4 décimas y 7
décimas o 3 y 47 centésimas ahora
veremos otra forma en la que podemos
colocar el valor en sus diferentes
posiciones vamos a dibujar una tabla
aquí en este ejemplo tenemos aquí la
posición de las unidades aquí en la
posición de las décimas y acá la
posición de las centésimas aquí en lo
que hicimos fue bastante directo son
tres unidades cuatro décimas y siete
centésimas pero hay otras formas de ver
esto por ejemplo hay alguna forma de
reagrupar todo esto en lugar de tener
tres unidades tenemos dos unidades y aún
seguimos teniendo siete centésimas pero
ahora cuantas décimas debemos tener para
que se mantenga el mismo valor pausa en
el vídeo y piensen en ello para
ayudarnos voy a copiar aquí lo que
teníamos acá arriba y la diferencia está
en que en lugar de tener tres unidades
ahora tenemos dos podemos decir que
estas son las dos unidades por acá
tenemos las siete centésimas
lo que tenemos que expresar todo esto en
términos de décimas como expresamos esto
en términos de décimas pues esto que
solía ser una unidad es equivalente a
diez décimas para que quede más claro
vamos a ver si puedo colorear esto con
verde y ahora vamos a dividirlo
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve y diez lo dividimos bien uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve y diez
sí y no lo dibujé muy bien ya que deben
ser diez secciones iguales pero como lo
hice a mano creo que ustedes me
disculparán noten que tome exactamente
el mismo valor pero lo reagrupe reagrupe
esta unidad en décimas cuantas décimas
hay aquí hay diez más cuatro
ahora hay 14 décimas esto es interesante
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora imaginemos un
escenario en donde de nuevo hay tres
unidades pero ahora en lugar de tener
siete centésimas
27 centésimas en este escenario cuantas
décimas hay pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo muy bien vamos a poner el
mismo número y pensemos en cómo debemos
reagrupar los valores posicionales
tenemos tres unidades esto es igual al
primer caso pero ahora hay 27 centésimas
por lo que además de estas 7 centésimas
tenemos que encontrar otras 20
centésimas lo más natural es tomar las
de aquí en donde 20 centésimas son lo
mismo que dos décimas queremos convertir
estas dos décimas en centésimas vamos a
colorear las y a convertir esto de aquí
en centésimas lo hice bien uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve y
diez
aquí lo tenemos esto más esto es igual a
27 centésimas cuantas décimas quedan
quedan dos décimas en esta situación
reagrupamos dos de la posición de las
décimas y las expresamos como centésimas
dos décimas se convirtieron en veinte
centésimas que es
a las siete centésimas que ya tenemos
aquí y ahora hay 27 centésimas espero
que esto tenga sentido